Saturday The Times published a piece
that once again hit Trump for not being
quick to respond to the virus it was
written by six journalists all of whom
could have or should have done something
sooner but didn't but alas the people
who keep saying you should have done
something sooner never say that to the
guilty party like The Times itself who
tweeted this On January 9th there's no
evidence that the virus a corona virus
is readily spread by humans oops and it
has not been tied to any deaths
double-ups
but health officials in China and
internationally are watching it
carefully so not only did The Times
dismiss the virus but also trusted China
would handle it thus endangering all of
us and we're supposed to listen to The
Times fact is if Trump had done
everything possible the press would have
screamed autocrat cuz that's what they
were screaming already they called his
travel restrictions which saved lives
racist they accused his task force of
not being diverse as if viruses have an
HR department the only crisis the times
can report on is that Trump's president
and about that acting to slow BS our
economy keeps the world of float I hope
we examined the effects of a shutdown
before we pulled the trigger if you
didn't you're an idiot or at times
editor so yeah we could have done it
sooner because everything good could be
done sooner but the people saying it now
couldn't be bothered then I could show
you how up into February the virus
didn't really excite the media at all
they were neck deep in the impeachment
sandbox and now they're taking it
seriously
why is that do we really need to ask
impeachment failed so let's try this so
Brett there were some news today yet
Trump had retweeted a tweet calling for
foul Chee to be fired and when that
created a little dust-up the White House
blasted the idea of firing foul Chee as
ridiculous he wouldn't fire foul Chee
they get along great blah blah blah so
my question to you mr. bear if you care
to answer it I love how the media has
spent two months trying to create a
schism between foul Qi and Trump and
when it appears that there might be some
they panic like oh my god there's a
schism that we've been trying to create
for two months then once again it's
pretty amazing watching this story you
know like it goes up like a roller
coaster and down like wait a second foul
she is not at the briefing where is he
he's he's not here and then down
President Trump says I trust him I want
to listen to everything he says and this
is what's going to happen today I think
he'll probably be asked the same thing
at this briefing today
now retweeting something that says fire
foul at the end is that advisable no but
but the White House quickly came out and
said he'd they're not gonna fire him and
he the president is pushing back on
really being attacked for a long time
and he retweeted something that showed
that Falchi at the end of January said
that the virus was not going to be a
threat to Americans or was a low threat
at best the bottom line is there's a lot
of blame to go around who said what at
the beginning the biggest blame should
be China and what they did and what they
didn't do and what they also didn't tell
the world about how contagious this
disease was I agree one would you agree
yes I'm sure you would that the
impeachment process of Bill Clinton took
our eye off the ball of al Qaeda and
radical Islamic terror which indirectly
gave us 9/11 and one could make the same
extension from that to this impeachment
charade that took us took the eye off of
the ball of the coronavirus no I don't
think that I think that the media I if
that's what you're talking about Gregg
like was that what was in the headlines
right right but I mean the president is
the president he gets information that
nobody else gets and what we know from
The Times reporting the Washington Post
reporting you know ap reporting is that
he was warned several times by even Mick
Mulvaney who was then his chief of staff
the National Security Council
Peter Navarro the economic adviser Alex
a czar at human health and human
services secretary and what the
President did was downplay a lot of
these warnings in fact when the woman
who handles respiratory and immune is a
nation said something without his
acknowledgement he basically said these
people are alarmist because it's
spooking the stock market so I just I
just think that you have to say the
president has some responsibility there
does the press I mean you I like what
you read about The Times thing because I
think it's a reminder
lots of people were slow to come to this
it's just that the New York Times is not
the president the United States it's not
the governor of a state and they have
information at a different level that's
why when dr. foutch ii was asked this
question yesterday on television he said
yeah if we'd acted more quickly lives
could have been saved I don't so I don't
I mean I like to look forward and say
let's get let's come together but I
don't think you can excuse the fact that
we were so slow to act and the president
was much more invested in what he calls
being a cheerleader for our nation than
in speaking to the threat and it was a
very visible threat being posed by the
coronavirus yeah you know and Juan
brings up dr. Fauci Jesse who was
telling people in March they could still
go on cruises so even the experts and I
do think that there was in the mind of
Trump in the mind of the experts there
was a value to them to keep the panic at
bay while they took came to grips with
this and discuss the big decisions about
shutting down the virus it wasn't a
denial phase it was what they were
trying to deal with incoming information
in which you would adjust your stance as
the information changed you weren't
trying to pull the wool over anybody's
eyes you were trying to protect the
country does that make sense I would
agree with that and I would also agree
with Brett that this all falls on China
Juan and the rest of the media are
comparing Donald Trump to perfection now
Donald Trump is he's not perfect and
he's not close to perfect either look at
what the media's perfect scenario would
have been they would have said Donald
Trump in the middle of a Senate
impeachment trial should have sent the
Senators home to their districts to
shelter in place Donald Trump would have
told all the voters of the country don't
go to the polls in South Carolina and
Super Tuesday stay home and shelter in
place you would have said
in February before one person died
remember first death in March first
don't go to Easter church services
you're not going to be allowed to go
could you imagine the reaction of what
would have happened if Donald Trump had
done that in February I mean you could
see the headline from The New York Times
right now American despotism right and
then Donald Trump would have tweeted
fake news and we all would have had a
big laugh about it but the point was the
travel ban came down at the end of
January and the full economic shutdown
came down mid-march that was six weeks
six weeks went by like that if you ask
me that was pretty fast and it wasn't
like this whole time in six weeks Joe
Biden won the New York Times every
scientists in the country were screaming
at Trump shut the economy down man shut
it down no they weren't saying anything
the whole month of February they were
talking about mini Mike and whether he
needed a platform to stand on in a
debate that wasn't in the country's head
so to go back and look at this and say
oh look what it could have should have
these are all just johnny-come-lately
hmm
you know Dana it is pretty funny when
you think back about what people were
consumed with and I still think that
that that for some reason we could the
media can only juggle one ball at a time
and it's the ball that that harms their
adversary you know I was thinking about
how all those days that I sat next to my
colleagues and Andy McCarthy and Martha
McCallum for literally hours and Bret
was in Washington DC with Chris Wallace
and we sat there and I could just feel
my rear end getting wider as we sat
there for hours and hours and I remember
saying like it would be great to cover
this China store if we ever could get to
it but Greg you've talked before about
how protected America feels because of
the oceans on either coast and the fact
we have pretty good neighbors and so
threats like this don't really
materialize for a while the other thing
I wanted to say is I've been a part of a
lot of look back stories Hurricane
Katrina
the 9/11 Commission report enhanced
interrogation the financial crisis those
stories are always something where
hindsight is 20/20 they have that saying
for a reason you can connect all of the
dots very easily if you look back and go
oh well here see you can obviously
obviously you should have done more and
the truth is when you're in the middle
of something you're dealing with the
information you have at the time maybe
you make the wrong call but then you try
to do better I think one thing the White
House communications team has to think
about going forward is that's one story
they look back they look ahead story and
what this country is gonna go through
economically and possibly health-wise
those stories are going to be even
harder to do so they need to be on top
of it and last thing if I I'm sorry I'm
I just wanted to say this about dr.
falchi this White House coronavirus Task
Force has mostly been available to any
outlet that asks and they're trying to
get the public information out there and
if you're a journalist that is trying to
figure out a way to drive a wedge
between the president and foul to so
that you could feather your own nest and
then worry that oh my gosh the president
might fire dr. pouchy but that's what
you were seeking you should really
really rethink that because dr. pouchy
is being as gracious as he can
president Trump is listening to him and
being gracious as well and my last point
is yes they did send out the statement
saying oh we never the media is being
ridiculous we never would have fired
Falchi it wasn't that quick though that
was a full like 18 hours before they did
that they should be a little faster if
that's what they mean yeah and and it is
a good point that mistakes when you make
a mistake everybody makes mistakes in
the fog of war its correcting them
quickly that makes you a successful
effective person I read that somewhere
in a self-help book